dr vega punk is one of the most
mysterious and influential characters in
all of one page he is the mastermind
behind the greatest technological
innovations of the one piece worlds he
has decoded and mastered the secrets of
the devil fruit managing to develop
artificial fruits smile fruits and even
a process for feeding devil fruits to
inanimate objects megapunk grew up on
karakuri island where frankie actually
spent his time during the time skip who
then used the doctor's advanced cyborg
technology developed for the pacifista
to add to his own cybernetic enhancement
another one of his crazy inventions is a
process for coating ships and weapons in
a mysterious material called sea stone a
mineral from the land of wano that wards
off the powerful seeking and nullifies
the power of devil fruit users in the
past vegapunk was in charge of research
on punk hazard and led a team called
mats consisting of the greatest
scientific minds in the world and yet
despite all that we still don't know
what he looks like and that's because